rampant cannibalism a horrific capture
and a folk tale that's lived on for
centuries The Hills Have Eyes was
inspired by the tale of a truly
terrifying family
1977's The Hills Have Eyes was only Wes
Craven's second movie and it helped
establish him as a well-respected name
in horror circles it already bore many
of the Hallmarks that would make Craven
a master of the genre such as franked
pictures of brutal violence a distinct
dash of social satire and a wry view of
America's darker sides maybe there's
some rattlesnakes prowling around Graven
was also known to draw inspiration for
his movies from real life for instance A
Nightmare on Elm Street was inspired by
a Los Angeles Times story about a young
boy who was the son of refugees from the
Cambodian Killing Fields as Craven told
vulture this boy's nightmares apparently
became so extreme that he died in his
sleep and thus Freddy Krueger was born
for The Hills Have Eyes Craven Drew
inspiration from a true story of a
Suburban family set upon by rural
cannibals as recounted by Tommy Hudson
in the documentary never sleep again the
Elm Street Legacy Craven found the
inspiration for The Hills Have Eyes when
he encountered the Scottish legend of
Sunny Bean while conducting research at
the New York Public Library as the
legend goes Alexander Sonny Bean was
born in the East Lothian region of
Scotland sometime in the 16th century a
disturbed and violent young man he was
lucky enough to find a wife who shared
his disturbing predilections a woman
named black Agnes Douglas unwilling to
conform to the world around them or deny
their base cravings for human flesh the
two retreated to a cave in the
countryside there they had several
children and through incestuous
relationships a few dozen grandchildren
in total the cave dwelling Clan was said
to have been almost 50 strong The Story
Goes that the beam Clans survived by
ambushing killing and then eating
Travelers and various passersby most
often victims were dismembered in the
cave after they were done eating the
beans would allegedly pickle what was
left over in barrels over the course of
approximately 25 years the bean family
were said to have killed and eaten over
a thousand people the beans were only
stopped when King James VI of Scotland
was alerted to the dangerous Clan the
king allegedly assembled a team of 400
men to hunt down the Sonny Bean family
and according to the BBC every member of
the family was executed though the story
features prominently in Scottish legend
there is no real proof that the Sony
Bean Clan ever actually existed what
seems to have fascinated West Craven
about the story wasn't just the sheer
brutality of The Bean family's actions
but the brutality of their executions
According to some versions of the story
the men of the bean family were
mutilated and left to bleed to death in
front of the women and children who were
then burned alive themselves per the
Scotsman in a 1977 interview with arrow
magazine Craven explained I was so
struck by hell on the one hand you have
this feral family that's killing people
and eating them but if you look at it
they weren't doing anything that much
worse than civilization did when they
caught them how the most civilized can
be the most Savage and how the most
Savage can be civilized this conflict
gave Craven the idea for one of the
signatures of The Hills Have Eyes in the
movie The surviving members of the
supposedly civilized Carter and wood
families end up resorting to the same
viciousness as the hill folk who have
attacked them by cleverly exposing this
brutal Behavior Craven reveals that
there's very little difference between
the families and the deep down all
humans are capable of committing
shockingly dark Deeds